نعم بالفعل ازدهار زبرو كانت اليوم عرضه
لهجوم صاروخي باربعه صواريخ بالستيه تقول
الاداره العسكريه هنا في الاقليم بانها
تتحقق من نوعيه هذه الصواريخ التي استهدفت
المدينه
وضواحيها هذا احد المنازل الذي سقط هنا في
بلده مافكا هذه البلده الواقعه في الضواحي
الشرقيه الشماليه الشرقيه ل زبروجيا وواضح
حجم الدمار الذي خلفه هذا الصاروخ
البالستي اضافه الى 12 منزلا اخر تضرر
بفعل هذا القصف الصاروخي الذي كان كما
يبدو يستهدف منشاه استراتيجيه حيويه قريبه
من هذا المكان القوات العسكريه الاوكرانيه
اغلقت كافه المواقع التي سقطت فيها
الصواريخ لاسما واننا نتحدث عن مناطق
صناعيه ومناطق
استراتيجيه يبدو ان الجيش الاوكراني غير
معني بان يتم كشف كشف النقاب عنها وعن
احداثياتها لكن نتحدث عن المنطقه الصناعيه
التي فيها العديد من المصانع مصانع الحديد
الحيويه وكذلك المطار المدني هنا في زبرو
جا القريب من احد مواقع القصف وسكك الحديد
بطبيعه الحال التي تربط منطقه زبروجيا
باقليم الدنباس وغيرها من المناطق من
الواضح بان هذا ال الهجوم الصاروخي الروسي
على زبرو ياتي في اطار تحول المدينه كما
هو معلوم الى خط امدادات للقوات العسكريه
الاوكرانيه المتو والمتقدمه في محور
زبروجوفكا
ما يفسر محاولات الجيش الروسي في الايام
الاخيره توجيه هذه الضربات العسكريه
للخطوط الخلفيه للقوات الاوكرانيه سواء
كان هذا هنا في مدينه
زبروجيا او كذلك الحال في البلدات القريبه
من خط المواجهه تحديدا تلك الواقعه في
اوري خوف ومالكا
تكشكش من الضربات ال الجويه والقذائف
المدفعيه التي يحاول من خلالها الجيش
الروسي توجيه ضربات عسكريه للخطوط الخلفيه
للقوات الاوكرانيه المتوغلة
هذا المحور وبالتالي نحن نرى بان القوات
الروسيه تحاول ان تسدد هذه الضربات للقوات
العسكريه الاوكرانيه وتلحق بين الحين
والاخر هذا الضرر الكبير نحن نتحدث عن 12
منزلا من المنازل القريبه من الموقع الذي
دمر باحد الصواريخ البالستيه تعرض الى هذا
الضمار الكبير عمده ميكولايف تحدث قبل
قليل على صفحه الاداره العسكريه التابعه
لاقليم نيكولايف وقال بان الصاروخ الذي
استهدف هذه المدينه في الساعات الاخيره
كان كما قال صعب الرصد من ناحيه الدفاعات
الجويه الاوكرانيه وقال انه ربما يجري
الحديث عن صاروخ
بالستي جديد لا يمكن رصده حيث ان صافرات
الانذار لم تدوي قبل انطلاق هذا الصاروخ
وتحذر منه وبالتالي سقط هذا الصاروخ كما
قال عمده ملايف واحدث اضرارا كبيره دون ان
تتمكن الوسائط الدفاعيه من اعتراض ويبدو
ان ما حدث هنا مشابه لما حدث ايضا في مف
من بلده ماتفك شمال زبروجيا مراسل الجزيره
سكرا شكرا جزيلا لك